-We are here playing the TV
game show classic "Pyramid."
Our special guests tonight
are Betty White
and Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good luck.
-I'm your host, Steve Higgins.
And, Betty,
who are you playing with?
-I'm Lars from Wells, Maine.
-Yeah! There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, Jimmy, who do you got?
-Hi, I'm Joanna
from Columbia, Maryland.
-Hey, very good.
-Oh, there we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And here's how we play.
You'll each be picking
a category.
Then you'll try to get
your partner to guess
as many words or phrases
in that category in 30 seconds.
The team with the highest score
after we clear the board
is the winner.
Any questions?
-No.
-Unh-unh.
-You sure? Alright.
-I don't have anything.
-You got anything?
-Best of luck.
-Oh, yeah.
Good luck to you, too.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Alright, here's the --
[ Laughs ]
Here's our categories tonight.
-Ooh. Okay. Farm.
-Betty, why don't you pick
the first category.
-Well, it's something I should
learn, but I haven't yet --
"Know When to Fold 'Em."
-"Know When to Fold 'Em."
These are things you fold.
We'll give you 30 seconds
on the clock.
-Okay.
-And...
-Alright.
Morning readable.
-A book.
-No, uh...
-Paper.
-Yeah. Uh, well...
-Newspaper.
-Nice. Got it.
Things you wear.
-A shirt. Pants.
-No, generally.
Clothes.
-Uh-huh.
Uh...
Moolah.
-Money.
-Uh-huh.
What you sit in.
-A chair.
-Right.
Lawn chair.
-Yeah, right.
And at the -- at the table,
a paper...
-Two seconds.
-Clip.
[ Buzzer ]
-A paper...
-Ooh. Very good.
4 points.
-Very, very good.
[ Applause ]
-Good job.
-4 points.
-How many, Higgins?
-That's 4.
-4 points. Ugh.
-Alright, Jimmy.
Are you ready?
-That was really...
-Okay.
-Choose a category.
-Alright, I'm gonna say,
'cause I spend a lot of time
in "June's Saloon."
-"June's Saloon."
-"June's Saloon," yeah.
-These are words that rhyme
with "saloon."
[ Laughter ]
So, the "oon" --
they have the "oon" ending.
Famous German umlaut
"oon" ending.
-Probably already think of one.
-We're gonna give you 30 seconds
on the clock.
-Mm-hmm.
-Are you ready?
-I'm born ready.
-Get set.
-Does this look
like I'm ready now?
[ Laughter ]
-That looks like --
You're right, that looks
like you were born ready.
-Ready.
-And go!
-A hot air --
-Balloon.
[ Bell dings ]
-You go to Apple,
you go to i--
-Tunes.
-Take the --
-Tune.
-Yeah.
Uh, it's not the morning,
not the evening.
It's the --
-Noon. Afternoon.
-Yeah. You look and see
full or crescent --
-Moon.
-To go to the bathroom,
you can eat a...
-Prune!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a -- Not --
It's a type of monkey.
But it's not an ape.
-Baboon.
-Yeah, and if I -- to get some
whale blubber, I would use...
-Harpoon!
-Yeah.
-Whoa!
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Cleared it!
No -- No, I wouldn't.
I would-- No. No.
Don't. Don't. No.
Aw!
-Okay, now it's serious.
-The mocking dance!
-Okay, now it's really serious.
-I mean, now I'm serious?
You know...
You know I played you
in beer pong and I won.
-[ Laughter ]
-I love someone
who not only wins,
but who reminds me
that he wins.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Lars, are you ready?
Pick a category.
-Good luck, sweetheart.
-Think I'm gonna go with...
"Catch Me If You Can."
-"Catch Me If You Can."
These are things you catch.
30 seconds.
-Things you catch.
Ready?
Lars?
-Ready.
-Go.
-Not the flu, but a...
-A cold.
-Yes.
-Not a bus, but a...
-Uh, a taxi.
-Not an airplane...
-Oh, uh...
-On tracks.
-Uh...
-Rides on tracks.
-Train!
-Yep.
[ Bell dings ]
This goes -- You either
hit it with a bat
or it goes in a hoop.
Or you throw it.
-A ball.
Yep.
This is something
you carry down the aisle
when you're getting married.
It's flowers. It's a...
-A bouquet.
-Yep.
This is something you catch
here in New York City.
Not a cab, but a...
-A taxi.
-It goes around town,
takes you from spot --
-A bus.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ooh!
-Ooh. That counts.
[ Applause ]
That counts.
-That counts! That counts!
[ Bell dings ]
-Nice. You got it.
-It's getting rough here.
It is rough. That counts.
-You got the full --
the full monty on that one?
-What's that?
-You got all of them?
-No.
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Score is 9-6.
-But I won't remind you of that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, you will.
-Joanna and Mustachio.
Joanna?
-Joanna.
-Let's do
"It's in the Bag."
-"It's in the Bag."
These are things that women
put in their purse.
[ Laughter ]
Which could be anything.
Well, you had
the "June's Saloon" on.
You know?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Ready, Joanna?
30 seconds on the clock.
Go.
-Okay, this is something
men carry usually.
It goes in your back pocket
with money in it.
-Wallet.
-Okay.
This is, um...something
you can call someone on
and it's got buttons --
-Cell phone.
-Yep.
[ Bell dings ]
These open your house,
your car...
-Keys.
-Yep.
This is, like, Orbit
or Extra.
And it's minty.
-Gum.
-These are things you get
from the cashier
when you pay for something.
-Recei-p-ts.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
This is what you, um --
Like, if Betty were to kiss you,
she would leave this mark
on your face.
-Uh...
-You put it on your mouth.
-I would never wash it, ever.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-Was it lipstick?
-Yeah.
-Ah.
-Lipstick.
-Alright, I didn't get
that last one.
-Or the last other one.
Betty, you choose.
You want to give or receive?
-That was good.
-Yeah, I'll give.
-Okay.
-And you have two categories.
Which one do you want?
-Uh, the...
"To Infinity and Beyond."
-"To Infinity and Beyond."
These are things associated
with outer space.
Things associated
Ready?
-Uh...
-Go.
-A star with a tail.
-A comet.
-Yes.
Uh...
All the little twinkly lights
in the sky.
-Constellations?
-No.
-Stars?
-Uh-huh.
Uh...
Then the big, round, white one.
-Moon.
-Moon, yeah.
-The guy who flies
in a spaceship.
-Astronaut.
-Mm-hmm.
-Foreigners
from other countries.
[ Laughter ]
-Cosmonaut!
No, foreigners
from other countries.
-Aliens.
-Uh-huh.
Those little things that --
[ Buzzer ]
...float around that don't have
people on them.
-Ooh. Asteroids.
-That was good.
-That was good. Not bad.
-Alright.
-14-11.
-Jimmy, you decide.
Are you going to give
or receive?
You need 3 points to tie.
4 to win.
-Okay.
-Up to you. You choose.
Your game.
-I don't want to bother you...
-I'd like to receive.
[ Laughter ]
-You're gonna receive.
-Yes, I think I'm ready.
-Joanna's gonna give.
-Ready?
-Yes.
-"E-I-E-I-O."
These are things -- you probably
didn't realize this.
"E-I-E-I-O."
Things you find on a farm.
-Things I find on a farm.
-On a farm.
-Mm.
-Mm-hmm.
-30 seconds on the clock.
-Wait, now.
How many do I need
for the win?
'Cause I can't wait.
-You need 4 for the win.
-I might want to make
eye contact with Betty
when I do it.
[ Laughter ]
-You need 4 for the win.
He's not gonna do
countdown fingers, is he?
-Here we go. Ready?
-Ready.
-Go.
-Okay, it's big and red
and has hay in it.
-Uh...
-Um, it's a building.
Um, and...
-A barn.
-Yeah, okay.
They crow in the morning.
Um, cock-a-doodle-doo?
-Roosters.
-Yep.
This is, um...
It's stuffed with straw
and he has no brain.
-Scarecrow.
-Yep.
This is something that pulls,
like, heavy machinery.
It's, um --
-Tractor?
-Yep.
And they say oink.
-Pig!
-That's it!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Ohhhh!
Whoa!
-Oh, congratulations.
-Now we're tied.
Now we're tied, 'cause you
beat me last time at Password.
-Oh!
-Yeah, we're tied.
Here's the real champ!
Betty White, everybody!